foreign
hello and welcome to our session on how
to build and deploy a cross-platform
application with flutterand.net
streaming from a symbol coffee
headquarters in London Esther and I are
going to take you through our
development experience on Google Cloud
so want to know how to develop build and
deploy a cross-platform front-end with a
scalable back end then grab a coffee get
online as we demonstrate our design
process and show you what we built
it's a fact my name is Esther hi and I'm
a customer engineer here at Google Cloud
hello my name is Francisco and I'm also
a customer engineer at Google Cloud
but today we're coming to you as
developers at symbol coffee our
fictitious coffee shop and what are we
going to demonstrate today Fran
well as the simple coffee wanted to
provide a more personalized experience
to Coffee connoisseurs by installing
kiosks in every store that let customers
visit their local cafe and order a
custom-made latte cappuccino or
macchiato made exactly how they like it
this experience should be consistent on
mobile phones and install kiosks running
Windows the application should scale
quickly as busy customers arrive looking
for their first caffeine of the day
now as lead developers we were tasked
with transforming the existing
application we had a very lean
development team Esther and myself and
wanted to be low cost and quick to
Market
wow that sure sounds like a grande order
let's see what happened and let's
preview what we ended up Brewing up
let's start by loading that plotter
application and seeing what that user
experience is like so here it is running
as a native Windows application and I
can enter my name and order some
delicious coffee drink hello
all right and here is the same user
experience in the web you can see same
look and feel no difference there that's
what we're looking for and hello again
okay well I think it's time to log in
and order a coffee
um so what I'm gonna do here is uh login
select a coffee put it in the cart and
receive a notification when it's ready
using a Dev test account
I log in
and here we go one very overpriced
espresso for me please in the card
submit the order
excellent It's roasting and soon will be
ready
we were given a lot of decision-making
power this meant selecting our cloud
provider technology and tools we chose
Google Cloud because it had the tools
that let us focus on building code
without having to manage underlying
infrastructure
see how we plan this out front
great let's start by looking at the
original application it is hosted on
premises there is a web front end and a
backend with a database where data on
connoisseurs and their orders is stored
this looks to me like it's your typical
three-tier pattern isn't it that's right
it has a web front end it's got a back
end and a database now currently all
components are manually deployed and
updated
yeah that's right and also we wanted to
make sure that the front end was
cross-platform to run on Windows and saw
kiosks we also wanted to transform the
applications of an architecture that
could scale efficiently making the most
of cloud native services
and automating the build and deployment
was very important to us as it would
help us spend more time on the code
itself
yeah and then as we were developing the
application we also just wanted to keep
our users at the front of our minds this
is where mapping the user Journey helped
and we decided that the user Journey
would have two parts in the first part
coffee connoisseurs would open the
symbol coffee app View and select their
product
our goal is to make this a consistent
experience on any platform be that
mobile or in-sore kiosks that's right
and then the second part involved adding
a coffee to the cart making the order
and sending a notification when it was
available to collect this would all be
handled by the back end which would need
to scale as more orders were made
so the copy connoisseur or even just
like us I guess would then pay for and
collect their caffeinated beverage at
the counter and they would sit and enjoy
next it was time to put our design down
on paper here are the components that
make up the application
the front end can be accessed as a
Windows application on install kiosks or
as a web app on your phone as you walk
into the cafe Maybe
these have a consistent look and feel
and then crucially for us developers or
friend and I
it did not require us to duplicate our
effort in developing them
meanwhile the back end is composed of
cloud native services that store data in
file store and communicate with each
other using Pub sub
but if you remember back friend before
we started our development Sprints we
reviewed our decisions just to make sure
that we'd select the right tool for each
goal indeed now we chose to automate
deployment from the start using Cloud
building Cloud deploy using a serverless
CI CD platform allowed us to focus on
building and deploying our software at
Great Speed without having to spend time
and effort managing those tools
that's right we also decided and wrote
down that we would write our front end
using flutter for cross-platform
applications written by that one team
friend and I and writing together with
the one language which is Dart
and finally we opted for a serverless
platform for a scalable back end we
chose Cloud run for independent updates
and serverless auto scaling for our free
microservices storing coffee order data
in Cloud firestore sending messages with
Cloud Pub sub and orchestrating the
events with cloud workflows
oh that was a lot of decisions wasn't it
now let's see what happened when we
actually hit the ground and got a lot of
caffeine in our system and started
coding let's go back and show you what
our two most exciting Sprints looked
like
the first prints we focused on building
a cross-platform front end
our first epic was to rewrite the front
end to flutter first we built the web
and second we used that same Dart code
to then build the application and run on
Windows devices
in the future this now allows us to
maybe build for iOS or Android
while our Windows applications would be
used on physical devices on store we are
hosting our web front end on Firebase
hosting that was just so we could
deliver our content fast and deploy our
web app with just one single command
so friend remember back how did we
iterate on our backend services so that
they could support our flutter apps
um on the web and in store
well Lester with the front end done we
started focusing on the back end
Services now critically we automated the
build and deployment for the front end
and back end using Google Cloud's CI CD
Solutions including Cloud build this was
so we could focus on deploying value
fast and making changes to our code we
then broke the monolith apart and
rewrote the backend Services to.net core
using build packs to containerize and
deploying the images to Cloud run with
Cloud build the free microservices could
now be updated independently
now all this work meant we now had a
customer coffee order app available on
web in store on Windows machines
supported with event-driven
microservices in.net and a scalable
serverless database
great by embracing Google Cloud
serverless offerings we were able to
spend more time improving our
application and less time managing
underlying infrastructure so you've seen
the final product but how did we get
here from our original front-end app
Esther is going to demonstrate now
awesome so now we find ourselves with a
flutter app vote for the web we have
supporting services and net and these
are hosted in Cloud run
there are a few changes that we had to
make to the flutter application first we
had to enable Windows as a platform with
flutter this means that every time we do
a flutter build we'll also compile to
source of both web and windows
amazing
to compile desktop application you must
build it on the targeted platform so in
this case a Windows machine
I've also had to pre-install the flight
SDK and dart
as the language in addition I'm using
visual studio code IDE
the reason I'm using this is that
because it gives me a consistent div
experience across both my Mac OS
computer and my Windows computer and it
enables me to Leverage The built-in
extensions such as Google Cloud code
extension and the flutter extension for
debugging in that hot hot copy reload
to add desktop support to a existing
flasher app let me show you how we run
the following command from a Windows
computer
cool so in the directory of The Flash
application we're going to do a slasher
create
flasher create platforms and then we're
going to Target the windows platform
and that's going to build all the
compiled native app code
and net current directory
amazing so you can see that's all being
done for us so now alongside the web
folder we've got a Windows folder
awesome so now that with the flutter app
built for Windows let's run it locally
and we're going to use the flutter hot
reload feature to then make changes to
the running apps and debug mode
we can change the text maybe in the dark
bar and then we'll compile and reload it
to the native Windows app
oh so I want to change the copy from
what is your name to please enter your
name I'm going to put this in now so
this is in the dot coat and then we're
going to hit save
we're going to see what this looks like
on the Windows application
so let's also change some methods that
gets displayed when we place an order
currently it's roasting
now this is handled by the
asynchronous.net order service that is
deployed in Cloud run and called by the
flutter application you can update this
to pro-wing and the order controller
we're going to push all these changes
now so the flutter generated Windows
application under the windows directory
the text on the step customer Dart file
and finally the message back from the
dot net order service
so we've pushed our changes to our
source repository and GitHub and now
this push will invoke a trigger in Cloud
build start our cicd Pipelines
these pipelines are defined in yaml and
are co-located and our mono repo
alongside the code in which they build
and deploy
these triggers were created with
infrastructure as code using terraform
which we can then reuse to deploy new
Services quickly maybe in the future or
after a couple more copies
even the terraform phone code gets
deployed through Cloud build meaning
that we can always trust our cloud
services and workloads are in a
non-state at all times
all right so we've pushed the changes
and now the first pipeline I'm going to
show is deploying the flutter web app
which uses a container to build the
flutter application for web and deploy
it it's drawn here on Firebase hosting
if the boot is successful then Firebase
hosting will then promote this build as
the newest release automatically
the second pipeline to show is boating
the.net order service container using
build packs and this is deployed to
Cloud run
much like Firebase hosting we can
determine how much traffic is being sent
to this newest release
we can see this here in the revisions
with the addition of binary
authorization we can attest that all of
the images that we were built with card
build in the dev environment are then
deployed to prod
so I'm ready for another copy let's see
the changes
so you can see here already we've got
please into your name which is deployed
through Firebase hosting I'm going to
place in my next order of a very
expensive coffee
and now we can see that back-end service
also representing Brewing
you know what actually I think roasting
worked better I I think it has it has a
it has a good sound to it
let's actually redirect all that traffic
back in Cloud run for that service to
that previous version that was
previously built with Cloud build
we're going to roll this back so I'm
just going to change the traffic here
save it
and this will deploy
now all we need to do to show that this
change has gone through
is create another order so yes another
another very expensive coffee just for
me
is to create
yes that's the order two why not and you
can see here we've gone back to roasting
amazing
you know what actually let's also roll
back that front-end posting as well
let's go back to that old copy on the
the front end to show what that text
might look like
a couple of clicks on the Firebase
console
and we'll do a hard Refresh on the front
end
another hard refresh there we are what
is your name and with that folks
so we've seen all these changes in the
web app
um but I think actually we're keyframe
what about the flutter native Windows
application
well of course we're using Cloud build
here again to build and deploy
cool so our Windows pipeline because if
you remember we can only build a Windows
application on a Windows OS behind the
scenes Cloud build here is using a
Windows VM on a compute engine
so we're spinning this up as part of the
plant plan
now we are also using a community
builder for cloud build here so once we
do have that Windows VM we are then
building another Windows container using
flutter and visual studio code so you
can see here this in the docker file
once we've built this we will then push
this container
to contain a registry
this is all done in the pipeline
and part of our Powershell script and
you can see here these are containers
and container registry
so this has now been used in another
script
um on the same VM to then be able to
build the application for flutter for
Windows just like what we did locally
amazing and just like that we have a
flutter Windows executable now that's
ready to store me being Google cloud
storage and we can deploy it to our
kiosks
and that's our journey so far so to
recap Esther and I were giving the task
of building an application that met the
changing needs at symbol coffee we built
a cloud native application starting from
existing components now throughout this
journey we opted to use platforms that
helped us focus on code and meet our
goals at speed
water allowed us to build
cross-platform application running on
web and windows our serverless back-end
Services deployed on cloud run allowed
us to focus on the business logic of
ordering copies
all without having to focus on the
operating and scaling of the underlying
infrastructure
and finally Cloud build as our
serverless cicd platform allowed us to
continuously make changes and deploy
all of these together let us focus on
what we care about most writing good
code and hopefully today we have
inspired you to do the same
or maybe you've seen some code that you
might want to improve in the demos
regardless thank you so much for
watching we hope that you found this
session useful
and we wish you a very good luck on your
Cloud native Adventures bye
[Music]